dzień dobry szanowni państwo
witamy na konferencji prasowej konfederacji w składzie
Marcin sypniewski Krzysztof tudu
drodzy państwo
my jako kierowcy znowu jesteśmy na celowniku eurokratów
chcą NAS ugotować Jak yy żabę ugotować powoli
to co dzisiaj podnosimy to przepis
który będzie yy zasady
które będą obowiązywały OD stycznia 2027 dopiero
ale już yy już są wprowadzane
yy i tak systematycznie yy Po trochę yy NAS
kierowców grillują
w jaki sposób
no oczywiście yy rozmawiamy o podwyższeniu
yy ceny yy paliwa
drodzy państwo
Unia Europejska pod wpływem dyktatu yy chorych
trzeba powiedzieć yy ideologii klimatyzmu
yy wprowadza yy system handlu emisjami yy co 2
yy dotyczy to nie tylko budownictwa
o czym yy nieraz yy już mówiliśmy
dotyczy to również
transportu i bezpośrednio przełoży się
na cenę yy paliwa
Jak yy obliczają eksperci
podatkowi yy
o 53 grosze zmieni się Cena litry litra yy paliwa
yy zostanie podniesiona i to jest yy szansa
dla porównania
yy prawie 50% yy akcyzy obecnej w polsce
która wynosi yy złoty 16 groszy za yy za litr
te przepisy dotyczą yy dyrektywy ets 2
która właśnie jest yy wyrazem tej
yy ideologii yy klimatycznej
i trzeba przypomnieć
że yy to jest związane z pakietem fit for fifty five
na który zgodzili się yy w osłowie pisowscy
zgodził się Mateusz Morawiecki
i nie Budziło to z przeciwu
yy w żadnych innych siłach politycznych
drodzy państwo
yy drodzy przede wszystkim kierowcy
w tym wypadku yy przypominamy
konfederacja OD początku jest Po stronie kierowców
chcemy taniego paliwa
chcemy taniego
yy państwa
nie chcemy ideologii w transporcie
yy i nie widzimy powodu yy
żeby takie rzeczy wprowadzać
konfederacja Po to idzie do euro parlamentu
żeby zwalczać takie szaleństwa
proszę o zabranie głosu marcina sypniewskiego
okej dzień dobry
szanowni państwo
Donald tusk obiecał paliwo Po zł5 i 19 groszy
natomiast Cena paliwa zbliża się do zł7
a Po wprowadzeniu tej dyrektywy
ets 2 będzie jeszcze drożej
ten skokowy wzrost
cen odbije się oczywiście na wszystkim spowoduje
że inflacja będzie rosnąć
a nie spadać yy i będą drożeć
yy ceny yy towarów i usług
yy czyli drożyzny
którą już teraz odczuwamy
odczuwamy będziemy mieli ciąg dalszy
a to wszystko w imię walki ze zmianami klimatu
tak naprawdę ta walka ze zmianami klimatu
prowadzona przez unię europejską sprowadza się do tego
że uderza ona w najuboszczych ludzi
a transferuje pieniądze do wielkich korporacji
które na tej całej polityce zarabiają yy
te koszty które wygeneruje ten dodatkowy nowy podatek
czyli yy czyli Po wprowadzeniu ets 2
yy mieszczą się w granicach około 5 miliardów złotych
tyle będziemy więcej płacić przez to
że Unia Europejska
yy kontynuuje walkę ze zmianami klimatu
polacy nie mają pieniędzy
polscy kierowcy nie mogą już więcej dopłacać do tego
żeby
yy wspomagać politykę klimatyczną unii europejskiej
my mamy zupełnie inne potrzeby
powinniśmy na coś innego wydawać yy pieniądze
yy powinniśmy wydawać na zabezpieczenie naszych granic
na poprawę bezpieczeństwa energetycznego
żywnościowego
na to powinny iść yy polskie pieniądze
a przede wszystkim to jest też kolejna forma podatku
któremu my jako konfederacja się
stanowczo sprzeciwiamy
uważamy że jeżeli w ogóle mamy płacić podatki
to powinniśmy je płacić tutaj w polsce
i tutaj je ustalać
a nie w brukseli
mówimy głośno
żadnych unijnych podatków nie chcemy drożyzny
nie chcemy płacić więcej w imię
walki ze zmianami klimatu yy
proponowanej przez unię europejską yy
dlatego właśnie
konfederacja musi wprowadzić
silną reprezentację do parlamentu europejskiego
żeby się tej całej polityce klimatycznej przeciwiać
żebyśmy nie płacili więcej
żeby nie było drożej i żeby
wszystkie te proponowane zmiany
nie uderzały w najuboszczych
i bronimy też Po raz kolejny polskich kierowców
którym znowu zamiast obiecanej obniżki cen yy benzyny
proponuje się kolejną podwyżkę
dziękuję bardzo
czy mają państwo jakieś pytania
dziękujemy bardzo dziękujemy